thank you very much Dan and I'd like to
thank carnegie mellon university and
atlantic council for inviting me for
those of you who ever heard of fed
speaker of the usual fed disclaimer
applies my remarks are my own and
they're not intended to be attributed to
the photo Reserve Bank Cleveland or the
Federal Reserve System it's indeed a
pleasure and a privilege to lead off
this very distinguished panel the
performance of national and
international financial systems is one
of vital importance to finance ears
non-financial business leaders
governments and citizens alike when
these systems work well they help the
channel capital to its most productive
uses around the globe they help economic
actors to manage risk and they help all
of us to defer consumptions of goods and
services to future perhaps to it to a
time when our expected incomes will be
lower when these financial systems work
poorly however people and institutions
may consider may experience considerable
losses ones for which sometimes they are
often wholly unprepared in the most
extreme cases when crisis of confidence
sweep through markets key financial
institutions may be unable to function
and they be often may be able to unable
to recapitalize and when these events
occur there can be significant spill
overs to the real economy during the
past year we have been witnessing a
contraction of private credit and many
developed and emerging economies private
financial institutions were scrambling
for liquidity reducing their credit and
risk exposures and trying to calm the
fears of their creditors central banks
and banking supervisors have been moving
quickly as well and now like all the
king's horses and all the king's men
policymakers are faced with the task of
putting Humpty Dumpty back together
again the question is how so I'd like to
address that issue and first provide a
little background
financial market regulations in the
United States and many other countries
became progressively more liberalized
since the mid-1980s during the same
period the United States became a huge
capital importer as significant amounts
of the world savings found their way to
our shores many large complex and
globally act of financial institutions
played central roles in raising and
managing these significant capital flows
financial engineering brought new
financial products to the marketplace in
the process credit market debt and the
value of financial assets to gdp
expanded dramatically in the United
States and in other countries as in some
other countries as well here are some
figures for the United States in the
second half of the 1980s corporate
profits from the domestic financial
sector amounted to only about half the
profits originating from the domestic
manufacturing sector now the tables have
turned during the past several years
profits in the United States from the
financial sector have easily outpaced
profits originating from the
manufacturing sector put another way in
1977 the manufacturing sector
contributed about twenty-two percent of
the total total value added to GDP in
the United States whereas the financial
sector contributed only fifteen percent
by the year 2007 these ratios were
nearly reversed the financial sectors
value-added rose to nearly twenty-one
percent and the manufacturing sectors
contribution fell to twelve percent by
the metric of profits at least finance
has become just as important as
manufacturing in the United States in
terms of value added to GDP some
observers of the current scene believe
that these figures prove that the US
financial system actually became
distended and grew to an unsustainable
saws that innovative financial products
and layers of intermediary may have
added value in a GDP account
sense but have violated some rules of
common sense many analysts predict that
it will be quite some time if ever
before financial sector reclaims its
former share of the corporate profits
pie in fact some regulatory reformers
seem to think that the whole point of
regulatory reform ought to be to rein in
the size and profitability of the
financial sector let me then turn to
some of the issues thought to be
critical to both the causes of the
current crisis and potential responses
to them in the current crisis some
systemically important institutions were
subject to little supervision this
facilitated increased risk taking and
made the resolution of troubled
institutions more difficult indeed some
financial market participants may have
considered these institutions to be too
big to fail too important to fail and to
connected to fail all of which frame the
difficulty financial system supervisors
have in adequately disciplining certain
institutions and markets market forces
work they work in the context of a
regulatory environment and that is why
so much thought is now being applied
toward addressing shortcomings of the
current environment otherwise
systemically important stand to gain
competitive advantage over other
financial system players and this in
turn could aggravate moral hazard
increase overall risk and reduce
financial system stability consequently
we should be interested in policies
designed to remove the advantages of and
provide disincentives for firms to
become or remain systemic ly important
the Federal Reserve Bank of Cleveland
has proposed on other occasions a
financial regulatory system containing
three tiers every financial institution
would be placed in one of these three
tiers and within each tier firms would
be created equally this system which we
call tiered parity would enable
supervisors to distinguish between
financial institutions that are systemic
ly important they would be placed in
tier 1 from those of system-wide
importance who would be placed in tears
and finally from those who pose little
or no risk to the financial system tr3
central to making this proposal work is
a regulatory philosophy that discourages
firms from becoming systemically
important and if they already are to
make them bear some of the costs that
their failure could impose on the public
well this sounds good you might say but
what makes a financial firm systemically
important size alone may not be the
answer recently we published a working
paper or a policy discussion paper by
one of my colleagues James Thompson in
which he builds on the tiered parody
concept that we had advanced early early
earlier James explains how a financial
stability supervisor could consider the
four C's concentration that is how large
an institution is in its market
connection that is the relationship
among institutions correlation which is
whether or not they have similar and
correlated risks in their books of
business and the context that is any
situation specific issues that need to
be taken into account and that financial
stability regulator could apply these
concepts to identifying institutions
that require the most scrutiny so that
brings me to the next topic in this area
which is defining the appropriate role
in authority for a financial stability
regulator institution by institution
supervision and regulation may doesn't
seem to be longer so any longer
sufficient to assure financial stability
we need to have a financial system
regulator that can assess risk and
vulnerabilities from a much broader
macro perspective especially in a
dynamic financial system such as ours
after all we should anticipate that the
players will change the products will
change and the markets will change and
therefore the risks will change the
Financial Stability regulator will have
to address the material gaps that open
up when these circumstances themselves
are changing
the financial stability regulator would
measure and monitor risks at an
aggregate level paying particular
attention to financial system liquidity
and financial system leverage the
financial stability regulator would
focus on the systemic risk factors such
as the four C's that I mentioned and
play an integral role in determining
whether a financial firm or market is
systemically important that is pay
attention to the context another issue
I'd like to cover today in the realm of
Prudential Regulation is the inadvertent
aspect of our current regular var
current regime to encourage financial
institutions to take on more risk in
boom times for example capital
regulations today tend to be procyclical
requiring banks to increase capital as
their balance sheets expand or tend to
be procyclical requiring banks the
increased capital as economic conditions
deteriorate this puts added pressure on
financial institutions to pair back
lending reducing credit during phases of
the economic cycle when credit
retrenchment can be most damaging to the
real economy conversely during periods
of strong economic growth financial
institutions tend to extend more credit
relative to their capital base and
become more highly leveraged counter
cyclical regulatory policies could
promote the stability of the financial
system for example counter cyclical
policies could require banks to increase
their reserves against future loan
losses during strong growth periods and
be subject to deposit insurance
surcharges during strong earnings
periods when they can most afford it in
addition to traditional capital
requirements we could also consider
whether innovative approaches such as
contingent capital would have a place in
our future regulatory system contingent
capital systems would be one in which
capital is automatically converted from
equity from debt to equity onto a bank's
balance sheet under certain
circumstances finally I'd like to
emphasize several issues that assume
extra importance due to the
globalization of finance
markets and institutions large complex
global financial institutions often
operate in dozens of countries and may
contains hundreds of subsidiaries and
yet the risk management and tech and
operating platforms of these
institutions may be centrally managed
the relationships among the subsidiaries
in the parent company can be very
complex during periods of severe
financial stress problems that these
complex institutions can present
significant coordination challenges to
the home and host country supervisors as
financial institutions headquartered in
one country become even more involved
around the globe it is likely that these
institutions will become more important
in their host countries and more
difficult to resolve should they become
financially troubled the relative roles
of home and host country supervisors
home and coast countries as supervisors
liquidity providers and ultimately as
financial backstops need to be sorted
out in addition how firms are structured
in the first place could have an
important bearing on the ability of home
and host country authorities to stepped
in and resolve problems it would appear
as though there are benefits from
greater international clarity on
resolution procedures for globally act
of financial institutions clearly there
are many challenging issues facing
financial institutions their regulators
in the global public the complexity of
these challenges should not discourage
us from restoring vitality to the
financial sector because I believe that
financial markets and institutions
provide services that enhance global
economic growth I'm looking forward to
the observations and insights of my
fellow panelists as we search for
answers to the many questions this
financial crisis has posed thank
mark thank you very much thanks for
kicking things off for us what I'm going
to do is pose questions to our panelists
probably more than one question to each
panelist and then we'll we'll open it up
for discussion looking at the g20 agenda
it's a pretty rich and broad agenda
we've got the issues of regulatory
reform we've got issues of finding
cooperative mechanisms to address
systemic risk we've got the challenge of
coming up with a blueprint for
sustainable economic growth that deals
with persistent surpluses deficits
rigidities and labour markets we've got
the problem of protectionism and how to
restart both trade flows and investment
flows and we've kind of got a wrapper of
coming up with accountability mechanisms
to ensure that the g20 and the g20
countries actually fulfill the
commitments they make not a small agenda
and a very challenging one before you
let me start with you on regulatory
reform what are the prospects for
agreement on regulatory reform that is
convergent and not fragmented in
ensuring that countries simply don't go
it alone on regulatory reform thanks Dan
it's a hard question to answer because
obviously the negotiations are still
proceeding I think in terms of answering
the question it's important to remember
that as you look at these international
summits and Dan knows well from his own
experience I know from my experience as
well that there's a business
nificant expectations management
dimension to be summits particularly as
the public perception going into a
summit is very set in in terms of what
the public expects will come out of a
particular summit so in previous summits
that I worked in and this was
particularly true in some of the day
nakade and I was in the audience worked
on in the Glen Eagle summit it was a
difficult dynamic that we went into
because the UK who was hosting that g8
summit had mayor it made very clear what
they wanted to see come out of that
event and so put a lot of pressure on
the participants to try to negotiate an
outcome that fulfill those expectations
and to put it bluntly didn't put the
host country in a difficult position
that's a that's a relevant context I
think to establish as we talk about the
different elements of the Pittsburgh the
agenda because there's a limit to what
international summits can do and there's
a particular limit to what inner leader
summits can do the issues of regular
financial regulation are biting it their
nature extremely technical extremely
complex and require very detail work by
line regulators the key values that I
think the leaders provide in which they
in particular provided in Washington and
also to a significant extent in London
had been to essentially develop a set of
principles that we're going to be
consistently and commonly pursued in
national systems among the g20 countries
there's an open question as we got go as
we're a sit here at the eve of the
Pittsburgh summit as to whether the
issue of reform is is is now still at a
level appropriate for leaders to try to
reach
Lucien not should leaders for example
use the next 48 hours to develop
technical rules on what capital
standards should be four different types
of financial institutions should they be
setting comp levels for different types
of financial institutions of different
of different character it's not to say
the government shouldn't be active in
those areas it's an open question though
whether it's an issue for leaders and
whether it's an issue that lends itself
to a high-profile public international
summit I think as we look at the
Pittsburgh summit I think it will answer
that question the bigger question about
whether the g20 is still at this level
of the globe at this stage of the global
reform a calendar still the appropriate
mechanism to deliberate kind of key
specific operational challenges because
for example if you look at the United
States the Obama administration's
already issued their regulatory reform
blueprint in June they've issued
regulation to Congress Congress has
already started moving different parcels
of the reform of package through the
relevant committees and yet now you have
a leader summit that essentially sits on
top of a national reform agenda that's
fairly mature in terms of how far it's
moving along and so that interplay is a
very complicated one and it's unclear
and we'll begin to see whether it's a
healthy dynamic or an unhealthy dynamic
but the big problem and you alluded to
to attend that the leaders can most be
Sigma most relevant to is the issue of
regulatory fragmentation whatever the
ultimate right public policy outcome is
in terms of financial regulation there's
no question that the rule set has to
have some consistency between national
systems because ultimately by their
nature kept capital markets and the
flows of capital are global and so
consistency of rule set is a critical
critical outcome and I think it'd be
hard hard to be able to draw the
conclusion certainly now and I think
it'd be hard to draw the conclusion 72
hours from now that the objective of
global consistency will necessarily be
achieved at the leader level it's beyond
typically it's beyond what the summit is
certainly a meter summit is capable of
producing certainly leaders are not
expected to write the details of capital
adequacy or liquidity requirements but
they can provide the political impetus
and it I'm often asked the question are
summits just photo ops or does anything
real happen the answer is something real
does happen but something real does
happen in advance of the summit and
between summits and we've seen emerging
a larger role for what used to be called
the financial stability forum converted
in London to the Financial Stability
Board and I wonder Tim since so much of
the work of the g20 on regulatory reform
will involve vesting different
organizations whether it's the FSB or
the IMF with authority to coordinate and
superintend how do you think that's
going to work out it's working it's a
great question Dan it is an enemy to say
before I raise the issue about whether
the g20 and political leaders should be
spending a significant amount of their
time worried about how much his boss is
going to make this year I think the
answer's no I think in some ways the
issues are tangential to why you have
these leaders together and in the
magnitude and enormity of the challenges
ahead and if the other issues that are
on the agenda climate change rebalancing
growth other issues which aren't on the
agenda probably should be how do we
think about the developing world and
and how they have been affected by this
crisis and how we make sure they're a
part of the solution so I think what the
g20 can do is to is to delegate to those
bodies such as the Financial Stability
Board which was you snouted was created
out of the financial stability forum was
created in London at the summit at the
Basel Committee and other institutions
that's the I met to bring that technical
expertise that bureaucratic expertise to
bear to to coordinate as far as notes
what is really still a very national
sovereignty set of actions Mervyn King
said banks live globally but they die
locally which is a reminder that it
really is national laws or sub-national
think about the insurance industry which
functions based on state law and so it's
not just national at sub-national but
not only national but regional just was
someone to Samia and note that the
European Commission today just passed a
series of new regulations so there are
regional groupings as well that bring
both techno expertise but a coordinating
component to it as well and I think
we're going to need it because I do
worry about fragmentation I do worry
about this the effect this crisis has
had on what appeared to be a
consolidation and a trend toward greater
cooperation and we may see it in capital
standards we may see an accounting
standards but I worry that there is
fragmentation but it I know in the u.s.
it's always about what can we get
Congress to do the president can
certainly make promises that at the end
the days got to be able to deliver
Congress that's not the problem many
other countries have because of
parliamentary systems and when gordon
brown or mr sarkozy says they're going
to do something then they have the
ability normally to get their
Parliament's to follow through in the
united states is much more difficult so
even that the president can say that we
are going to do the following things we
are going to coordinate it really is up
to Chris Dodd and and Barney Frank in
the house and
other key players in Congress to ensure
that those kinds of actions actually
come to fruition and that what we do in
Washington is consistent with nellie now
but in the future what others are doing
other capitals thank you to you
mentioned President Sarkozy so I'll use
that as a segue in the run-up to these
summits there's always a drumbeat about
something and somebody is always
threatening to walk out before the
Washington summit the furor was about
unregulated hedge funds before the
London summit it was about tax havens
before this summit it appears to be
about bankers bonuses now none of these
three issues was a principal cause of
the crisis and remedying these three
issues would not ensure that a crisis
didn't happen again so we've we've seen
a lot of furor about compensation should
there be caps should there be ratios I
think we're seeing a consensus thanks to
the efforts I think of the US
administration moving us towards a
sensible set of principles to discourage
excessive risk-taking to align the
interests of the individual with the
long-term performance of a firm and to
provide clawback of compensation if
performance deteriorates but borrow I
want to turn to you there is a in the
drumbeat in the press as there was
before London this idea that human greed
human behavior particulars decisions and
incentive structures were responsible
for the crisis what role from your perch
do you see for risk management and
sounder judgments
picking up from the last last comment we
want could an important asset that any
institution has is this intangible asset
of the trust that people have in it
enables them to to do things to sustain
political support to raise capital and
we've taken a big hit in the in the
intangible asset of the financial
industry through this last period and
then you know many of the industries
that we will be looking forward to solve
our problems in energy and technology
have a rocky road in their relations
with the public so their ability to
sustain take a nuclear power or carbon
capture and sequestration or GM crops
anything that if as an investor I would
want to know that there's going to be a
stable regulatory environment before I'm
making an investment all of these
institutions need to be able to protect
their reputations and typically if you I
think with the psychology the research
shows is that people are if you do your
work right people can understand the
risks and benefits of most technology
it's not as though these are outside the
grasp of the public but typically we
don't do our work right so it's
difficult for the public to figure out
what the deal is or the public is
distracted by all the other things that
they're doing in their lives and as a
result the the perceived trustworthiness
of the people who are in charge of these
institutions is taken as the and it's
not as a signal for whether or not they
should be should be trusted and that
trickles through to the political system
and the economic system and and it's not
an invalid measure so even if say the
compensation problem is just a small
part of the overall thing you know
perception of unwillingness to deal with
the compensation problem this is not a
non diagnostic indicator of how
trustworthy trustworthy this is so I
think we face a strategic commitment to
make this information the right
information
accessible to the public and that means
a kind of meaningful disclosure and then
we faced a kind of boring technical job
of making certain that the information
is is comprehensible to people so one of
the things that I do I chair an FDA risk
communication Advisory Committee and as
we know the pharmaceutical industry has
taken some large reputational hits
recently we have a mechanism for
consumer medication information the
sheets that you get at a pharmacy in the
United States it's a real technological
feat to get those one pagers to
everybody's hands but they're basically
incomprehensible I mean everybody knows
that it's now it's now established and
the pharmaceutical industry has an
opportunity now to come up with the kind
of information that the that the public
public needs of the public felt that the
pharmaceutical industry was leveling
with it then there would be more trust
in it there would be a better balance in
the regulation with with with that FDA
that FDA would do and it would basically
allow for the better people with the
better products to do you know to do
better so it's kind of boring technical
work but it's not work that we're doing
and I think we have the same sort of
disclosure issues with financial where I
think we're much further behind in
figuring out what it is that we need to
tell people so they can make appropriate
decisions thank you Dave let me turn to
you if if the developing country model
of export-led growth is no longer
sustainable because the developed world
model of consumption is not going to
come back in the way it was what role do
you see investment flows playing in
economic development in the developing
world and in contributing to the
recovery more generally well thank thank
you very much opportunity here before
answer the question let me just see a
show of hands of how many of people in
the audience are students okay and how
many of you are
engineering students okay how many of
you think that the g20 has any impact on
you at all too so try to take dance
question and try to demonstrate that it
actually does first point is that
foreign direct investment matters for
economic work that matters for economic
growth in the recipient country and also
in the exporting country economists
disagree on just about everything but
one thing they virtually all economists
agree on is that foreign direct
investment creates economic activity
produces higher paying jobs and
generates higher levels of Rd and
development second thing that's
important particularly for those
students in the audience and those who
live in this part of the country is that
foreign direct investment is
particularly important for manufacturing
and technical skills so five percent of
the jobs the United States are supported
by FDI but twenty percent of the jobs in
manufacturing broadly defined are
supported by FDI and what's happened
over the last couple of years with the
financial crisis is that the levels of
FDI have plummeted just gone off the
charts just give you a few data points
in the United States inbound FDI is down
by about half outbound FDI has gone down
by almost seventy-five percent Europe
it's about fifty percent in China
inbound FDI which was going growing like
crazy dropped twenty percent last year
same in India 56% Japan which
historically has had unusually low
levels of inbound FDI even those low
levels dropped by eighty percent in the
financial crisis okay
the one positive development has been
the outward flow of FDI from developing
countries which gets to your question of
this this is a critical part of economic
development not only in in Brazil China
Russia India although Russia's kind of
fallen out of the bricks and now it's
really bix in many ways so to give you a
couple data points outbound investment
in China from China has grown more than
20 times in the last eight years
outbound investment from India has grown
five times in the last four years that's
all positive but the level of that
investment is still tiny so India and
China last year had about 20 billion
dollars of X of outbound FDI that's a
significant growth over the previous
years but it's still tiny so the amount
of outbound FDI that the United States
reduced its exports of capital by in the
first quarter of this year was three
times larger than the overall FDI of
China's outbound investment overall okay
so this gets to back to the final point
which is what does this mean for the g20
and what does this mean for the students
in the room well a critical question for
the for the leaders of the developed in
developing countries are what is their
attitude and what is the policy they're
going to have towards inbound FDI which
is so important for growth particularly
manufacturing particularly for Carnegie
Mellon students the first is will the
g20 leaders send a signal that they want
this investment do we want chinese
investment do we want india investment
do we want investment from the middle
east in this country my view is it's
critically important second is in an
environment where banks are hurting and
where other pools of capital are
basically dormant governments have
stepped in and become much more
important
providers of capital and government
agencies both at the multilateral level
IFC the world bank etc and national
level agencies like oh pick exum have
become even more important not own the
United States but around the world and
hopefully the g20 leaders will commit to
expanding that and third is avoiding
investment protectionism which so far in
this downturn has gone fairly well there
haven't been a lot of examples of too
much investment protectionism but the
jury's still out so the bottom line is
that FDI policies and promoting more FDI
is absolutely critical for developed
countries and developing countries and
the g20 will have a big impact on the
signals that are sent to boardrooms and
pools of capital all around the world in
terms of whether their capital is
welcome well the picture on investment
protectionism may not be to give there's
been a lot of attention focused on trade
protectionism and some believe in fact
that the administration kind of enters
this summit agenda item under a bit of a
cloud not only because of the recent
decision to impose import restraints on
Chinese fires but because of a record of
inaction on trade liberalizing
initiatives since taking office the
Korea South Korea Panama and Colombia
FTAs have not been submitted by the
administration there is kind of a
nuanced ambivalence of the
administration on Doha so many kind of
are wondering what the u.s. leader can
do in this summit to credibly continue
the fight against protectionism but more
than that to actually begin trade
liberalizing measures and Lee I wonder
if you could comment on what the g20
could do here and what would be
considered a worthy
livable well that's an interesting
question and in addressing it let me let
me sketch out a bit of a historical
context right first of all the g20
delegates are dealing with the largest
downturn of the global economy since the
Great Depression and that historical
reference point is obviously very
important many of the leading economies
of the Great Depression era turned their
back on global trade embraced
protectionism raised tariffs and as a
consequence made the Great Depression
much worse no one wants that to happen
again right to prevent a relapse towards
protectionism there's a push to restart
the Doha Round of trade negotiations and
even if we're not successful in that we
want to try and hold the line right not
to give in to the temptation for further
trade protection so even if we can't
push the trade liberalisation forward we
don't want to move backward but history
teaches that it's very difficult to
resist those temptations in a weak
economy so you know I think that you
know the recent and broadly over a
Chinese higher imports is an interesting
example right the administration has
recently decided to raise tariffs on
tire imports this was a case that was
not brought to the administration by the
u.s. tire industry which gave up on
domestic production for the low end of
the tire market sometime ago that was
brought by the United Steelworkers
there's nothing in the case that
suggests China is doing something bad
engaging in illegal subsidies breaking
world trade rules you know the crime of
the chinese producers is that their
exports are rising at a time when
domestic demand is down and american
jobs are at risk and you know obviously
there's there there are a number of
issues here including the importance for
this president of keeping allies engaged
at a time when the health care debate is
the center stage and probably you need
trade unions to support that but we've
seen this before in the early 1980s
which was probably the last time we had
recession anywhere this severe in this
part of the country even a president is
ideologically committed to free trade
principles as ronald reagan had to bow
to political
pressure to place de facto quotas on
Japanese exports of cars to the United
States the political pressure was just
too great and more recently after nine
eleven when the u.s. steel industry
created of the administration of George
W Bush levy tariffs on steel imports
that the WTO later ruled were illegal
and had to be dropped and when you
compare the Obama administration's trade
you know the trade restrictions imposed
by the Obama administration at least in
terms of its immediate economic
ramifications to the trade restrictions
imposed by the Reagan and Bush
administration's at least so far they're
not as large indirect economic terms
furthermore if you want to take an
optimistic view of this and I do I
actually think that this will probably
not be a immediate threat to the multi
hundred billion dollar trade and
financial relationship that currently
connects the People's Republic of China
and the United States i mean the chinese
may look for opportunities to retaliate
they may find some i don't think that
we're headed towards a trade for war
with china and for the most part you
know recent events notwithstanding i
think the major economies have done a
decent job of resisting the urge to
relapse into protectionism thanks could
have been a lot worse I'm a little bit
less pessimistic when the attention
turns to the prospects for restarting
the Doha round as many former Bush
administration officials know this round
was actually started right after the 911
attacks which helped put the major
economies in recession and then as now a
major push for trade liberalization was
viewed as a useful antidote to the
temptations of protectionism but the
Doha round has been going on for eight
years now the negotiators have been
contented with convincing with very
complex and difficult issues and a lot
of political counter push and if
progress wasn't being made at a time
when the global economic environment was
much more favorable I think it's going
to be very difficult to persuade voters
that it's in their interest to increase
competition and reduce subsidies at a
time when
the economic environment is very adverse
i wish i could say otherwise there are
two critical issues confronting
international trade negotiators right
now we're developed in developing
countries are very much at odds one is
agricultural subsidies and the other is
actually climate change right i mean the
US Congress over the objections of the
president has decided to add to the
climate change bill a provision that
allows the United States who impose
carbon tariffs on imports of carbon
intensive goods from countries like
China and India that do not appear at
this stage to be willing to engage in a
really restrictive carbon control policy
the Indians in the Chinese claim that
any attempt by the United States
actually do this would be contrary to
WTO rules it's not clear that they're
correct in their legal interpretation
but nobody disputes the strength of
their convictions and as long as this
feature exists in u.s. legislation or in
the legislation of other major Western
nations I think it's going to be very
difficult to make headway on further
substantial liberalisation now in my own
opinion I think that the climate change
problem requires the full engagement of
all major emitter is including China at
some point it may be appropriate to
think about trade counter measures as
one tool that might be able to persuade
them to restrict their own emissions but
I think the timing is not right now but
of course a climate change bill that
doesn't include this provision might not
pass Congress so unfortunately whenever
economic logic and political logic
collide it's often the latter that wins
at least in the short run holding the
summit in Pittsburgh this year rather
than Washington you know the United
States is not alone in debating what I
regard as ill-considered border measures
as an inducement to greenhouse gas
emissions mitigation the continental
Europeans have come out strongly in
favor of it too not clear to me how much
play climate will get in this g20 it
appeared that climate finance might be
an important issue for a time
we haven't heard much about that
recently mark let me finish with a
question to you and then i'm going to
ask my panelists if any of them wish to
comment on a question that I posed to
somebody else and Mark if this gets too
close to the zone of those are the
things you can't talk about in public
and I'm happy to reformulate the
question but my question is should the
Fed be this systemic risk regulator well
that's certainly a very active
discussion for my part I when I get
asked that I try to get people to focus
on the issues more than who's chosen
that's why I emphasized in my remarks
the need for having an institution that
can do this certainly as an organization
the Federal Reserve has a great deal of
experience and expertise and the
capability of performing at performing
admirably in that role but certainly
Congress is going to have to take a look
at how they want to do that so so while
I say that you know we're well equipped
I think it's also very important that
whenever there's legislation about this
that the incentives are properly dealt
with that is that the systemic regulator
is given the right tools to do the job
appropriately that we don't have
something that looks on paper like it
should work but when you get right down
into the details of it the the right
tools and authorities won't be there to
make it effective so that's that's my
shorthand answer to that Tim did you
have a comment I just want to echo what
David was talking about in the need for
capital I was just out in among the GCC
countries a few weeks ago
and what you're hearing from same thing
I here in Asia and a lot of other parts
the world is we're sitting on tremendous
amount of dollars we'd like to invest in
the US but we worry about it we can't
get visas we worry about the sippy asst
process we but the u.s. is very
attractive to us but there are a whole
host of burdens and hurdles and
challenges and the political environment
is so charged we just don't feel
comfortable no debut your firm here's
that frequently because you've got such
a large presence in so many of those
places we need foreign capital to run
our economy every single day we also
need foreign capital to buy our
Treasuries our budget of us this year
will be around twelve or thirteen
percent of GDP a historic high since the
Second World War we're going to issue at
least at least nine trillion dollars
worth of net new debt over the next ten
years and we need foreign governments
foreign savers to continue to purchase
those Treasuries even with the higher
savings right here even with a portfolio
shipped out of other assets into
Treasuries even with a reasonable
assessment of what corporate profits are
going to be we are going to be importing
capital for as long as we can possibly
see in enormous magnitudes and we need
to make sure that we put in place the
right kind of environment and send the
right kind of signals that we welcome
that investment here or we will pay more
money for it and that has real
macroeconomic implications Thank You Jay
the occasional xenophobia one sees in
respect to foreign investment I think
some of our earlier panels mentioned
both the scope of non-competes and US
immigration policy as deterrence to
innovation domestically and for those of
you who may not be familiar with this
particular aspect of protectionism the
United States Congress actually wrote
into law that financial institutions
receiving assistance under tarp could
not benefit from the h-1b visa
program and to me there is no more
crystalline form of protectionism or I
would say unamerican ism in terms of our
tradition of welcoming immigrants than
that little rule for Europe a couple of
things one is on that point you just
made in terms of immigration excuse
answer about the terms of restrictions
on bringing for workers and for firm
like ours which is very global by its
nature h-1b restrictions are obviously
an enormous problem because we we are a
firm that ultimately based on the skill
of our labor pool and so the degree to
which we can get the best and the
brightest globally is critical for our
ability to compete and serve the needs
of our customers but it's even more
important to understand that for every
one or two foreign workers that we bring
into the United States of work in our
headquarters in New York and Chicago or
elsewhere there's many many multiples of
those of Americans that we send to to
Europe to Asia to the Middle East to
staff our offices and there and in Latin
American elsewhere and so when when the
United States does impose restrictions
on the ability of American companies to
bring form workers they are setting into
motion as surely as the as the Sun sets
the the process of potential retaliatory
action and other jurisdictions that
ultimately will have many multiples of
the times and impact on our own workers
and working in foreign markets just a
couple of things one is on but David and
Tim said on investment protectionism and
the importance of encouraging the flow
of capital is obviously very right I'm a
little less sanguine about that than I
thought I heard Dave of being in part
because we haven't seen a lot of
investment protectionism because in part
because the the financial slowdown has
limited significantly the amount of
strategic investments that have occurred
over the last 8 months 10 months 14
months or so as the market begins to
stabilize and deal activity begins to
pick back up we're against the real test
I think as far as I'm concerned will
begin to confront us about where the
tenor lies certainly in the United
States these investment deliberations
that each administration has to go
through including this the stickiest
process which is the process by which
the American government reviews foreign
investments that determine whether
there's a national security threat or a
very subjective in nature and they're
not like it's not like trade where you
can articulate a position for good or
for ill in terms of how you view where
foreign where you stand on foreign
investment virtually everyone any part
of the political spectrum will tell you
that they're in favor of more FDI but
they simply want to be careful about
protecting against national security
threat so it becomes an extraordinarily
subjective process and Tim having
chaired the sophia's process when his
time in Treasury knows that in the end
of the day these are very difficult
judgment calls that you may or may not
get right and at times as a senior
public official as Tim was ultimately
sometimes turn on decisions that could
threaten your own political career
frankly and that's a hard thing for an
experienced administration to navigate
it's a particularly harder thing for a
new administration to navigate so
they'll be interesting to watch dan if I
could without filibustering just one
more thing the g20 that the summit
itself is very interesting because it's
now become I think widely perceived to
be the preeminent global summit
pretend it has at least in so far with
its limited history has become a very
action-oriented summit in terms of
really making decisions that have a real
impact and with real constituencies
among the countries that are
participating the hardest decisions that
the g20 have made as made so far all
relate primarily relate to regulation of
capital markets and even then the
regulation of the more developed capital
markets it will be interesting as the
agenda the g20 expands whether the
commitments and the disciplines that are
undertaken in the context of financial
regulation are embraced by the emerging
economies the bricks and others who who
have had it a less of an extensive
history of participation in
international summits and less of a
history of getting involved in
negotiating international commitments
that have to be ultimately implemented
it'll be a very interesting thing to
watch as the summit agenda broadens is
the issues in play widen to see the
degree of follow-through and the degree
of evolution that we potentially would
occur or maybe lack of evolution in
terms of the comfort level of certain
new entrants to play the game of
international summit tree thank you very
much let me open up to questions yes sir
could you speak up unless we have
microphones thank you
they teach that free market economy
interest rates are lower when the public
has a lot of safe bank I was going
through savings significant interest
rate and engorged borrowing and spending
your system is not a free market economy
the Federal Reserve artificially lower
the interest rate which encouraged a lot
bari and white spirit what useful now my
question is we blame the Republicans
then-current rebounders all to some
folks existed but one we blame the
Federal Reserve well let me start with
saying there's some element of
correctness to the economics but it's a
not a full picture so in the broad
scheme of things interest rates in our
economy and determined by a number of
factors they are determined you're
correct savings close and we've talked
about the large volume of international
capital flows into the u.s. beginning in
the 90s and then getting increasingly
large as we headed into the most recent
period these large inflows of capital
certainly played a significant role in
lowering interest rates broadly in the
United States the Federal Reserve has
very direct control over very short term
interest rates but there's a spectrum of
interest rates in our economy longer
term interest rates that are both say
risk-free in the form of Treasuries but
rates that carry risk with them such as
corporate debt subprime mortgage debt
and so on and these rates
reflect some component of the very
short-term element but also they carry
term premia they carry liquidity premium
a carry risk premia so at any point in
time in our economy there's a very broad
spectrum of interest rates the general
level does shift up and down primarily
with the supply and demand for savings
it's only really at the very short end
that Federal Reserve policy plays an
important role and so I think that you
know your analysis points to a period in
the early part of this decade where
monetary policy was quite accommodative
as we came out of a recession short-term
interest rates were low but I think ex
post most an analysis in my own is that
the risk premia embedded in a lot of
financial products turns out ex post to
be very low we went the risk premia
embedded in a lot of financial market
instruments were not really adequately
reflecting what should have been charged
as the full price of risk to people who
are bearing it and that's why we got too
much too much capital channeled into
financial assets because the price of
them in some sense was too cheap
and you hear in the back I don't think
recently the question is very short most
of the populace would you agree with the
recommendation to make banking boring
again in other words do you think that
the benefits of financial innovation in
the last decade have exceeded dependent
Pittsburgh hey um I would say that most
banking still is boring and was boring
leading up to it I mean if you think
about the development of the banking
sector basically the entities that we
think of as banks really only provided
less than half of the capital available
for borrowing that more than half came
from non banks which became lenders and
these were hedge funds pension funds
insurance companies and variety of other
non banks and many of the banks that we
traditionally think of as banks stop
being banks and really became
syndicators of debt so that they would
not loan the money themselves but they
would maybe low in a small part of it
but then go around and say well you know
I'd like to have you put in ten percent
of this loan and you put in five percent
the thing that strikes us at carlyle
when we think about what happened and
we're looking to buy banks right now is
when we go and do due diligence on a
bank and we've looked at over 200 banks
in the last two years we are shocked
with the exception of course of bank of
new york
at the unbelievably poor decision-making
an absence of just fundamental
underwriting standards that existed at
banks and non-banks so we recently
bought a bank bought part of the bank in
Florida the heart of the housing crisis
two-thirds of the mortgages that this
bank issued prior to us buying it were
issued with no documentation it was just
crazy so it was it's a so the banks need
to go back to being good risk managers
doing a good job at due diligence doing
a good job at underwriting and the
regulator's need to make sure that that
that's what the banks are doing I don't
think that coming up with you know 17
new agency is going to solve a problem
it's basically human judgments going
back to the professor's points
Brad senator you mentioned the climate
change legislation be one of the next
major issues and I wonder you mentioned
the major contention between foreign
Terrans on target do you think of this
problem to be mitigated if we do not
give away our domestic permits as we
have shown that we would Congress would
really really like to do do you think
that would if we actually charge them
for that would be kind of internal
terror that would mitigate the political
effect yeah so under a cap-and-trade
system if you want to buy somebody off
right if there's an industry that's
exposed to competition from in a country
which doesn't have strong carbon control
laws one of the best ways to do it is to
hand out free permits to that industry
right now from a strict economic you
know efficiency perspective auctioning
off every single last one of those
permits to the highest bidder is the way
to go a lot of economic studies show
that auctioning off the permits
dramatically mitigates the economic cost
of carbon control but here is a case
where you know the the affected
industries actually do have a point
right and furthermore from a global
carbon control perspective if you
quickly and dramatically raised the
price of carbon in some part of the
world but don't change it in other parts
well some capital is mobile right I mean
why wouldn't the aluminium industry just
pick up and move not immediately of
course but over time to the unregulated
jurisdictions okay I mean the problem of
course is that at the moment there is no
political will I guess you could say it
within the major developing countries to
put a serious price on carbon okay so if
we want to move forward with a global
negotiation process right and we want to
include these countries but not try and
push them be
on where they're willing to go then we
have a real problem on our hands right
imposing a high price of carbon in the
United States without some kind of
compensatory policy to these effective
industries is going to be politically
difficult to do thank ya thank you sorry
borrow this situation it's worth
distinguishing between sort of inside
the beltway politics and national
politics so on climate change there's
been a majority of public support and
survey since the early 1990s and it's
the support is at the level of do
something about this just like there's
public support for doing something about
the health care situation in the United
in the United States and and then once
you get inside the beltway our notion of
doing something is incredibly
complicated there's all sorts of side
payments they're suspicious ways of
doing things and it's as though you
can't you know there's a I don't know
perhaps a contradiction that that
anything that will mobilize the public
will seems to be demoralized by the way
we go about doing business but I would
say would include cap and trade which
looks like a shell game to a lot of a
lot of people and yet is our way of
doing these fine side payments and that
perhaps what we you know our choice
might be one of actual political
leadership that would sacrifice some
theoretical economic efficiencies for
actually doing something and it's not
clear to me that you wouldn't be able to
mobilize both on health care and on
Climate you wouldn't be able to mobilize
it an electoral majority at the same
time you'd lose your inside that you
have you know that might override the
the predictable friction within the
Beltway all right yes
interesting
it's a good question to ask because in
part it sort of tells the story of what
a summit is all about because there is a
very very comprehensive agenda of work
that was launched at the Washington
stomach in november of last year was
reinvigorated or given a further
political backing in the london summit
in the spring of this year and now is
going to be subject to review and status
checks and things like that when the
leaders me and so this ongoing work
agenda is being done in part by
negotiations among the national
governments you know in terms of the
finance ministries or in the leaders
offices but then also through these
mechanisms that Tim alluded to like the
Financial Stability Board the IMF has a
role the Basel Committee has a role
that's a ver variety of international
committees and they've been their
membership has been adjusted so a lot of
countries participate and there you know
the deliberations are going on and all
these different for it's hard to know
who's raising what issue in what setting
but what happens is what Dan described I
think at the at the beginning of the
session which is there'll be a headline
issue that a certain country will pop
out and that becomes the sort of the
defining the political politically
defining element of the negotiation that
so for this summit that politically
defining a issue is compensation the
Germans the French and the UK now have
signed up on a common position that
they've gotten the Europeans together on
that is now essentially the the big
issue in the play in terms of what the
leaders do you know will there be some
sort of very strict and hard
restrictions on the compensation levels
of financial sector executives as a
result of the meeting that's going to
occur over the next couple of days and
that's sort of a vision so if you want
to talk about kind of big issues that
are in play because of other countries
that's probably the big issue capital
requirements are now big as well if I
could there isn't a kind of developing
country view on capital adequacy that
these are not issues which break
developed developing when you get down
to fine points of financial regulation
your typical division is transatlantic
or those who have universal banking
systems versus those who traditionally
did not and so a lot of the squabbling
is kind of almost below the radar on
accounting standards or other issues
that would have a real significant
impact on the current solvency of
financial institutions in one country or
the other were they to break one way or
the other but it's not a developed
developing country divided I think in
the u.s. one of the you know what are
the interesting things about the way our
crisis developed is that we have a
history of problems in the banking
system and there's well developed that
is the commercial banking system well
develop procedures for failure
resolution you know the FDIC they have a
lot of experience with how to do this
the FDIC itself is financed through
assessments on financial institutions
there's sort of a model for how to deal
with that and when the the problems
emerged there were so significant
outside of that commercial banking
system and it became evident that there
was a significant financing problem for
how to deal with failures that's where I
think the public you know the public
really sort of
sniffing sort of head snap back when
people began to see that there are a lot
of dollars that needed to be channeled
to dealing with the failure resolution
of these institutions and in the past it
was a pretty self-contained well
understood system and that sort of
called a lot of attention to the
inadequacies and the sort of piece
piecemeal system of the US financial
regulatory model whereas again in some
other countries we have more universal
banking systems the role of the state
you know as a sort of ultimate guarantor
is is more clearly understood so we're
seeing I think you know people coming to
grips in the US with the fact that de
facto our financial system you know now
has to encompass much broader set of
risk management tools outside of dealing
with just problems in the commercial
banking system and that's really
fundamentally what all the legislation
is about it's how how the US regulatory
system in some sense can catch up to the
way the financial system itself has
actually evolved thank you Gary littman
US Chamber one of our sponsors thank you
the United States an historic release
their case do you think this crisis
change fundamentally and the way
compositions people Majel to use happen
deal the good private sector take us as
credible voices and these are going to
be a difference in the way the United
States government future will go out of
the prime 70 will go back the model
before the crisis reflections on Gary
I'll give you a quick thought and then
we'll go down down the road it is true
that the November summit last year was
called and then held 24 days later there
was even within that short period of
time a pretty significant amount of
consultation between US financial
regulators and in the US financial
sector between the White House and the
financial sector but I have to say I
think we were able to achieve consensus
not only internally but also across the
g20 in such a short period of time and
it's such a strong way because of the
depth of the crisis we were facing I do
not see the fact that that consensus was
achieved quickly as a threat to
transparency or a council tation quite
the contrary I do think there is a
concern that is more authority is
devolved by the g20 to the financial
stability board or others that don't
have the habit institutionally of
consultation that that could be an issue
I think I think officials would probably
argue someone like Hank Paulson are Ben
Bernanke here Tim guy herb good argument
here in crisis they were on the phone
repeatedly and consistently with leaders
from the financial sector so I think
there was real time feedback on what
policy they were proposing and how that
might affect the financial sector either
for good or for ill because some of it
is with other the political realities of
what was driving policy and some of it
was seen as punitive to the financial
sector but it's my suspicion that top
officials were in constant contact with
the financial sector maybe not maybe not
necessarily a non financial sector maybe
they should have been in closer contact
with GE Capital you know the
non-traditional financial players that
really didn't have a regulator but will
in the future I suspect so I think there
was engagement going forward I think
we'll see more of that engagement
pre-summit and as a part of the summit I
think what we learned as Congress and
Washington gears up to sort through this
regulatory process that the financial
sector specifically in other parts of
the corporate sector industrial sector
have a real voice and nothing will come
out of Congress unless the industry is
certainly supportive or at least not
hostile to what's occurring so I
actually think that we will see
interaction and did and then we'll prove
positive going forward we have time for
one more question I thought I'd guess
so we mentioned a lot about regulation
and risk management in the banking or
one of the things that I'm wondering
about is how should non banks or less
traditional energy capital financial
institutions be regulated or how should
the government risk management practices
less traditional life private equity
funds like hedge funds and other
institutions at ways of heavenly great
question I mean youryour if I could
reformulate it somewhat there's been a
great deal of attention on risk
management practices of financial
institutions deemed to be systemically
important because if they have poor risk
management it's not just they who fail
but we all who suffer and I think your
question is isn't that true of some very
large interconnected global
non-financial companies as well and what
is being done on that front Bora
effective so compensation incentives are
a major part of risk management I think
the compensation problem has actually
been sort of Miss identified if we had
evidence on what the public was
concerned about it's not that somebody
is making so much money is that as
picking up on Dave's point is that
they're making any money at all or that
they're not even or that they're not in
jail and so I think a part of the
regulation which is compatible with free
market systems is have courts that will
more aggressively enforce inappropriate
behavior without getting into specifics
of individual proposals you know I
commented before that incentives really
matter so another set of incentives
would be you know that people who are
funding these financial institutions or
other commercial banks are not really
have to view their funds at risk that is
they have to take a much more active
role in monitoring the credit risk
management
of the institutions in which they're
investing same would be true about
counterparty exposures part of the
system then requires a credible that the
regulatory apparatus has a credible
ability to to close an institution or
you know to resolve it when it's at risk
so if you're a creditor and you think
this institution is too complicated to
be allowed to be unwound or to fail you
know and I know that because I don't see
any credible risk resolution on the
horizon that gives you more you know
more of a sense as a creditor or a
counterparty to be relaxed about
monitoring your risk but if you see a
credible risk resolution authority out
there willing to step in and you as a
creditor or funder may may seriously
take a loss in that exposure that you
know that stiffens your backbone a
little bit more to monitor risk so it's
a whole set of reinforcing you know
elements in the system and you know
that's why I think focusing on the
economics as opposed to who's the
regulator and whose proposal makes the
most sense we want to try to get some of
the some of the elements of risk
management built into the system so that
the private market can operate
effectively to discipline institutions
the way it should and you have to have a
good regulatory apparatus to back that
up if it I think you have the last word
sure I think that one thing that's clear
out of this crisis is that every part of
the financial system will be regulated
so hedge funds private equity funds
others forced forms of capital mortgage
banks industrial loan corporations if
they're allowed to exist the private
equity for example there has not been a
mandatory regulatory requirement Carlyle
and several of the other large private
equity firms voluntarily registered with
the SEC even though we were required to
do so because we thought it first of all
we got large enough that it was
appropriate and second of all we
ultimately said it was a comparative
advantage of us for us to tell our
investors that were regulated
there now will be a mandatory
requirement that all pools of capital
private equity firms energy funds hedge
funds are registered with the SEC as
long as there are over 30 million
dollars which is fairly small in Europe
there are similar proposals that
Europeans have taken a different
approach one which raises some concerns
because they the proposal they have on
the table seeks to regulate all forms of
alternative pools of capital as though
they're exactly alike so for example
there are requirements in there that
simply wouldn't apply to our business
model it would be like regulating a
insurance company as if it's a bank so
we're working with European regulators
to try to address some of the issues
they've put on the table but at the end
of the day any significant form of cap
pool of capital any significant player
in the financial system will be
regulated punch eyes because I believe
we did not give you a good answer to
your question actually and I think
that's because we really don't know the
answer to it it is an excellent question
there are non financial institutions
that can pose risks of all kinds and I
think we just haven't gotten to the
point where we are looking at that for
your will have the last word if you
actually look at the definition of
what's a Tier one financial Holding
Company and the administration's
proposed systemic risk legislation it
actually doesn't it limit it to
financial institutions and so it's a big
question you know it's a financial
holding company but the
edition of the term is purely based on
the impact of that firm should it
collapse so it's a big question in terms
of how exactly is the Federal Reserve
going to go about and does it have the
capacity to regulate a non-financial
that by virtue of its business practices
or business model could if it were to
fail cause systemic risk so for example
the auto companies have financing arms
but the fact that they were rescued
wasn't necessarily because of the
financing arms I think from it was
because they were so interconnected to
their supplier base and what have you
that the the administration the Obama
administration was worried about the
systemic risk implications of that so
the question resting is a big question
there is an answer to it but it's not a
settled answer it's it's a first shot at
that answer right but thank you well as
I said at the outset the g20 has a very
rich and broad agenda we've managed to
touch on a number of issues on this
panel and with the kind assistance of
your questions we managed to touch on
others please join me in thanking our
panelists